in 2014 ukraine erupts into crisis which
unfolds on many levels
first in kev when massive protests in
the streets lead to the fall of the
government and the escape of the ousted
president viktor yanukovych
then the situation turns into an
international crisis as vladimir putin
of russia moves in special forces in
uniforms without emblems and a nexus
crimea a region of ukraine on the black
sea
fighting breaks out in eastern ukraine
between the ukrainian army and rebels
supported by russia and in july a
malaysian airliner is shot down as it
crosses eastern ukraine with all
passengers and crew killed
a succession of ceasefires are brokered
and then broken several million become
refugees and the fate of a nation hangs
in the balance
after the collapse of the soviet union
many experts warned of ethnic violence
on a mass scale in the former soviet
union but it did not occur
so why now
for decades after world war ii the
violent changing of borders had been
considered a taboo in europe given the
cascade of turmoil that would follow
the prospect largely became unthinkable
with the tragic exception of the former
yugoslavia
so 2014 was in a sense
a pivotal year
as eastern europe again saw borders
altered by violence and the threat of
force
as part of ukraine crimea was annexed by
russia
and putin announcing that ukraine as a
whole was a failed state sent his forces
into eastern ukraine
and yet the tinder for this explosion
didn't just spontaneously come into
being in 2014.
in fact neither did the larger emergency
about the recent difficult post-soviet
politics of transition over the last two
or three two to three decades
rather the background to this crisis is
a slow-motion identity crisis involving
both ukraine and russia and extending
back over centuries
it has often been noted by scholars
that russia without ukraine is a country
but russia with ukraine is an empire so
one question that arises is
what sort of russia comes into being
if it chooses an imperial identity with
an appetite for expansion that threatens
its neighbors
or if on the contrary russia chooses a
self-sufficient identity that meshes
with modern europe today
for ukrainians their identities are both
linked to those of a past shared with
russia
but also with historic ties and
affinities with the west
ukraine is marked by a diversity of
historical memories and orientations
and in that sense it's like a microcosm
of larger eastern european patterns that
we've been exploring in this course
but with one big difference
while many attributes of eastern
europe's history derive from the
challenges that face smaller countries
and ethnic groups when they confront
bigger outside imperial powers
ukraine is different in its sheer size
after russia ukraine is the second
largest country in europe and it's the
largest country located entirely inside
europe
ukraine is the size of texas with a
population of 45 million
it became famous as the bread basket of
europe because of its tremendously
fertile black soil the chernozem
from that rich earth spring up amber
waves of grain and also fields of
sunflowers
in this sense the flag of independent
ukraine blue over yellow is in fact a
literal rendering of the landscape
idyllic sky overproductive acres
it also suggests the level flat
geography that has shaped ukrainian
history as a contested area whose very
name means
borderland
the tides of history also carved out
divides in ukraine that still persist
today
after the golden age of the roos
centered on kiev the mongol invaders
swept in
after a time of predominance the mongols
areas of control shrank leaving the
tartars of crimea as their descendants
then poland and lithuania moved in as
well
they left an imprint on the society and
politics of ukraine while also endorsing
the creation of a ukrainian uniate
church orthodox and tradition but bound
to the roman catholic church
ukrainian nobles assimilated to the
manners of the polish elite
beyond the areas of foreign control lay
the wild realm of the ukrainian cossacks
those free fighters who escaped feudal
regimes in order to live entirely by
their own independent code
like the american cowboys cossacks
became famous for their horsemanship
their fighting skills and their rough
and tumble independent ways so it's
little wonder that later ukrainian
romantics idolize the cossacks and these
mythologized heroes even show up in
ukraine's national anthem
wedged between the powers of poland
lithuania to the west
and russia in the east the cossacks
maintained a balance between those
powers until they could do so no longer
and had to choose one or another side
for an alliance
in 1654 the cossack warlord both don
minitsky who had led an uprising against
poland and sought to create an
independent state for the cossacks
signed a treaty with russia at pereaslav
historians have been arguing ever since
for centuries after about that treaty's
true meaning
manitski received in this treaty the
tsar's protection along with russian
promises for ukrainian autonomy
instead of getting an ally who would
defend their existence however the
cossacks discovered that they now had a
set of new rulers because in 1667 soon
afterwards poland and russia came to an
agreement among themselves for partition
they divided the contested ukrainian
lands along the upper river
throughout this course we've seen again
and again that recurring phenomenon of
partitions in eastern europe and
stubborn resistance against them
this partition was eventually made moot
by the decline of one of the partners
poland lithuania and its division by
other great powers
for ukraine the final end of poland
lithuania by 1795
meant that most ukrainians were now in
the russian empire with one exception
the proud province of galicia in the
west
actually fell to austrian rule under the
hopsburgs
so here
a new west versus east contrast emerged
in ukrainian history
in the areas under the russian empire
policymakers assumed that the slavic
populations or little russians as they
called them would eventually melt into
russian culture a greater whole
the empress catherine the great labeled
the regions that she had won near the
black sea
novoracia new russia
a name which clearly pointed to the
intended future of a unified expanded
russian imperial identity
ukrainian language was banned books
outlawed and nationalist intellectuals
persecuted
but by contrast in the west in the
austrian empire where the state had to
play a complicated game of balancing
ethnic groups off against one another
ukrainians or ruthings as they were
formerly called were actually able to
cultivate a modern national identity
literature and culture
we've noted how the end of world war one
brought some attempts at ukrainian
independence but these failed
between the world wars ukrainians again
found themselves divided by borders
most living in the soviet union
others in poland romania and
czechoslovakia
inside the soviet union as we saw stalin
cracked down on ukrainian cultural
leaders and brought mass death with the
terror famine or holodomor of the 1930s
with the coming of the second world war
some ukrainian nationalists hoped that
nazi germany might help their cause
among their leaders was step on bandera
before the war in poland bandera was
active in the organization of ukrainian
nationalists which waged a campaign of
assassinations against polish officials
at the start of the second world war
ukraine some ukrainian nationalists
allied with nazi germany and some
participated in the nazi campaigns
against the jews but as ukrainian hopes
for independents were frustrated
relations deteriorated and the nazis
arrested and imprisoned bandera
a new force called the ukrainian
insurgent army or upa arose opposed to
the nazis and soviets
and it violently aimed to ethnically
cleanse poles from the areas that they
claimed killing tens of thousands
by the war's end
a strange hidden three-sided conflict
was roaring in these regions between
banderas ukrainian nationalist
guerrillas
polish underground fighters and soviet
partisans
in a previous lecture we noted how
towards the end of the second world war
borders and populations were shifted in
eastern europe ukraine saw key examples
of this stalin deported all the crimean
tatars from their homes expelling them
overnight
poland shifted westward ethnic poles
were evicted from ancestral homes and
the city of levovov became leve
in ukrainian in western ukraine by the
end of this process ukraine's borders
included most ukrainians for the first
time in centuries
but all of them under moscow's rigid
control
the second world war had uprooted many
and this contributed to a vast diaspora
of ukrainians around the world but
especially in the united states and in
canada they number in the millions due
to repeated waves of immigration or
escape since the 19th century
marina levitzka's 2005 novel a short
history of tractors in ukrainian is a
most engaging comic novel that depicts
all the complexities of successive waves
of immigrants from ukraine coming to
britain and their interactions with each
other and with their new home and i
recommend this book most highly
within ukraine partisan warfare
continued into the 1950s as in the
baltics
the guerrilla leader bandera remained in
germany where he was hunted down by the
kgb and assassinated in munich in 1959
a final change of borders was then
affected by stalin's successor nikita
khrushchev who had actually been a top
party official in ukraine before and
after the war
to celebrate the successes of the soviet
union
and to mark one particular ancient event
three centuries before
in 1954 khrushchev officially gave
crimea to the republic of ukraine
the old anniversary that was being
marked was the 1654 treaty of periyaslav
between russia and the cossacks
now given the fact that all the
republics in the soviet union were in
fact ruled from moscow the border change
didn't seem at the time anything more
than a formality but it ended up ringing
down to our times
below the surface of soviet life even as
ukraine's formal existence was written
into the state structure
russification still preceded a pace in
eastern ukraine a large part of the
population were russian speakers even if
they identified themselves as ukrainians
in the country at large bilingualism was
common because russian held pride of
place as the language of international
brotherhood in the soviet union about a
quarter of people in ukraine today
identify russian as their mother tongue
especially in the east
dissident voices in the soviet period
were strongest in the western parts of
ukraine because of its different history
these were the parts that had been
sovietized more recently and remembered
a different non-soviet past
in the period of glasnost and
gorbachev's reforms the dissident rook
movement which was the people's movement
of ukraine
championed ukrainian identity in ways
that were similar to the independence
movements in the baltics at the time
protests were sparked by the chernobyl
disaster and how the state hid its
impact so environmental protests grew
the banned union church also resurfaced
after being underground for decades
towards the end of the soviet period
even ukrainian communist officials
endorsed independent statehood
with the collapse of the soviet union in
1991 ukraine became independent
in a referendum on the question over 90
percent of voters were in favor of
independence
however in what followed the newly
independent ukraine revealed yet more
complexities
along with russia and belarus ukraine
was one of the founding members of the
cis the commonwealth of independent
states
yet many ukrainian leaders avowed that
they wanted to be part of an eastern
european return to europe as well
which would mean orienting themselves
and ukraine towards the west and its
institutions
how could these commitments be combined
at the same time
the population of independent ukraine
was diverse including ukrainian-speaking
ukrainian ukrainian-speaking russian
ethnic russians jews and crimean tatars
who had migrated back to the homeland
that stalin had once evicted them from
several competing branches of the
orthodox church also claimed the
loyalties of people of that faith
at the same time both the state and
economy were in bad condition
the slow and very fitful economic
transition favored those who were well
connected so soon a class of powerful
oligarchs rose up and these super-rich
founded political parties of their own
as sort of personal vehicles for
advancement
bribery was an integral part of a an
entire shadow economy that actually
carried over from soviet times
in the year 2000 secret recordings
allegedly captured the president leonid
kuchma's voice
as he ordered his entourage to deal with
a troublesome muckraking journalist
and soon after the journalist in
question giorgi gongadze was later found
dead
corruption at multiple levels of
government ate away
at ordinary people's confidence in the
system and economic productivity lagged
ukraine found itself hugely dependent on
russia for energy supplies some 75
percent of its gas and 80 percent of oil
supplies
to overcome its troubles ukraine sought
international financial aid to prepare
for reforms
and giving up its big nuclear stockpile
left over from the soviet era in 1994
helped win them some international
assistance
over time disappointment with insider
politics as usual produced a popular
movement called the orange revolution in
ukraine in 2004
this was prompted by disgust with the
cynical manipulations of elites
especially one in particular
the ukrainian opposition to the
government was led by viktor yushchenko
earlier an economist and head of the
central bank in ukraine
as candidate for the presidency his
coalition promised to fight corruption
bring uk ukraine closer to the west and
to set the country on a new course
but then on september 5th 2004 yushenko
went to dinner with the deputy head of
the ukrainian intelligence service
later that evening yushenko became
desperately ill
medical tests showed dioxin poisoning
symptoms and the symptoms indeed were
visible on his bloated pockmarked face
who had done it
several suspects fled to russia and
could not be questioned
was the intention to kill him outright
and remove him from the presidential
campaign
or was the intention merely to disfigure
him in his outward appearance and thus
scuttle his chances for election
whatever the case it backfired
when the government announced fraudulent
election returns
people took to the streets
they chose that vivid color orange to
rally people to their cause and flags
and shirts and they kept protesting even
in that bitter winter cold out in the
streets
one in every five ukrainians went out in
protest in the orange revolution but
there were contrasts there was that
divide between east and west
one in three people in the west
protested but fewer than one in 20 in
the eastern part of the country in the
capital kiev the demonstrations rocked
the city's independence square
the so-called maidan nezales
over 17 days the protesters finally won
and in a new election that was held
yushenko became president
yet what followed was a disappointment
and that still puzzles experts trying to
understand why this was
rather than making common cause
those who had loudly championed reform
instead got bogged down in struggles
against one another
there was little sense of progress being
made
capitalizing on people's frustration
radical ukrainian nationalist groups
some of whom celebrated stefan bandera
as a hero started to gain more support
then in 2010
viktor yanukovych was elected president
with most of his support based in the
eastern regions
and also with the support of russia's
leader vladimir putin
yanukovych told nato that ukraine which
had been considering membership before
was not interested in membership and
indeed the population was very
ambivalent
yanukovych also jailed his opponent
yulia timoshenko a co-leader of the
orange revolution and a former prime
minister accusing her of corruption in
office
at the end of 2013
when yanukovych bizarrely first
negotiated and then refused to sign an
association agreement with the european
union
again mass protests erupted in kiev
leave and other cities
centered once again on kiev's maidan
nizolognosti these protests in the
coldest winter came to be popularly
called the euromaidan or euro square
protests
government forces tried to quell the
portrait of the protests so-called
berkut officers were specially charged
with crushing demonstrations
the berkut were forces like the zomo
police had been in poland or the oman
special forces in the soviet union
in the suppression of the protests
dozens of protesters were killed but by
february 2014 president yanukovych felt
that his power was crumbling and he fled
finding refuge in russia
there then followed strange scenes
as hundreds of thousands of protesters
now wandered around in yanukovych's vast
estate near kiev
an estate which showcased the wealth of
an oligarch at its most ostentatious and
outrageous
the grand mansion had been built in a
rambling and eclectic bombastic style
that locals started calling donetsk
rococo after yona kyanukovich's hometown
donetsk
the mansion was set on a larger
territory of 350 acres it was surrounded
by a private zoo of exotic birds and
deer
tennis courts a helicopter pad and
winding landscaped gardens with pillared
pavilions and pleasure domes
at this point the entire complex was
declared to be the property of the state
and plans were elaborated for using it
as a museum of corruption
but then questions of the ownership of
the estate got bogged down illegal
complications in the courts
emblematic of the whole tangled
processes of government in ukraine even
after the overthrow of yanukovych
also emblematic
of problems and confusion was a mystery
that surrounded some of the loot that
was on display there
persistent rumors insisted that among
yanukovych's many toys
was a loaf of bread made of gold
but it disappeared in the looting and
tramping through the palace and now
officials claim that it never really
existed at all
putin who had been yanukovych's patron
declared his ouster and the change of
government in kiev illegitimate russian
media denounced the protesters as
neo-fascists and nazis
they called them banderovzi recalling
world war ii and the guerrilla leader
stefan bandera
russian forces moved into crimea
at first the russian government denied
that it had sent troops into the region
which had an ethnic russian majority
the troops that arrived there were
joculy referred to as
little green men
noah knew where they were from
perhaps from mars
they brought they bore no insignia on
their uniforms but they did wear masks
russia then annexed crimea officially
over international protests
news reports suggested that inhabitants
of crimea who opposed the annexation
have faced violence and crimean tartars
who make up some 15 of the population
are anxious about their own fate in
their own homeland once again
later in march of 2015
putin proudly admitted openly what his
government had earlier denied that he
had masterminded the annexation of
crimea from the start
it was not a spontaneous response to
calls for help from locals but a plane
and the annexation in fact had been
ordered weeks before the referendum was
staged under the watchful eyes of gunmen
next heavily armed rebels many again
wearing masks started seizing
territories in eastern ukraine along the
russian border and declaring many
republics under their control
they were self-appointed administrators
of this region and one observer
memorably labeled this the republic of
random dudes
russian media referred to the
territories by a new name
or rather revived an old name
these were called novoracia or new
russia precisely the name given to our
next lands by catherine the great
in july 2014
malaysia airlines flight 17 was shot
down as it crossed over eastern ukraine
near the border with russia
the plane had been bound from amsterdam
to kuala lumpur and all 298 people on
board perished
rebels at first did not allow
international investigators to the crash
site
as fighting continued russian officials
insisted that none of their soldiers
were in ukraine
but when russian prisoners were taken
it was announced that in fact they were
soldiers on vacation who could do what
they wished in their own free time
however the russian government went on
to declare that the deaths of russian
soldiers during peacetime were a state
secret
which opened to prosecution by the state
anyone who reported on funerals back in
russia of men killed in ukraine
communal conflict also blazed up in
areas with mixed populations
a particularly dreadful incident took
place in the famed port city of odessa
with about 30 russian population
in may of 2014 pro-russian and
pro-ukrainian protesters clashed and
molotov cocktails were thrown leading to
the deaths of about 42 most of them of
the pro-russian group a full
investigation was promised by the
ukrainian government but was badly
managed so the event still remains
unclear
by 2015 in spite of ceasefires
negotiated in minsk in belarus and then
broken before the ink was dry
the fighting had already taken some 5
000 lives and had turned upwards of a
million people into refugees
civilians living on the front lines were
subjected to shelling
mortar attacks and cross crossfire
a whole zone of the country now was
dominated by a state of undeclared war
and the question presented itself
whether one wanted it to or not is this
the new normal in europe
back in 2008 vladimir putin reportedly
told us startled president george w bush
during a summit meeting that ukraine is
not really a country
as the crisis unfolded in
2014 the president of the european
commission called putin in august to
seek some resolution to the crisis
putin's reported reply was that he could
occupy kiev in two weeks
the background to this perspective was
putin's declaration that the soviet
union's collapse was the greatest
tragedy of the 20th century
the cultural and educational policies of
putin's regime have praised the soviet
union and revived its symbolism and
vocabulary
the biting irony here is that in fact
russians had been victimized by that
system longest
living under its control longer than
other peoples absorbed later in eastern
europe
in that sense this represents a hangover
from the end of soviet empire and
communism
yet putin's policies led to a surge in
his popularity back home
a deliberate manipulation of news and
media sought to sway public opinion in
russia and abroad
tv in russia aired interviews telling of
atrocities one woman claimed that
ukrainians had crucified the infant son
of a rebel
it was later learned that she was the
wife of a berkut officer involved in
suppressing protests and the story was
never confirmed nor retracted
polemics surrounded the shooting down of
the malaysian airliner including claims
that everyone on board had been dead
already and that the incident was a
western provocation
putin's government argued that its
intervention was motivated only by
concerns for order in ukraine which had
become a failed state
here were fascinating historical echoes
from all the way back to the late 1700s
when the great powers had justified
carving up the state of poland lithuania
with precisely the same claims
one unspoken reality was that in fact
disorder was encouraged by the outside
powers quite deliberately a revival of
civic order within the target state
would actually threaten the partitioning
power because it would offer a different
and attractive alternative form of
government
but a key difference in this case was
that rather than a series of great
powers looming over and vivisecting a
country here russia alone was taking the
lead
the russian extreme nationalist
politician vladimir jeronovsky leader of
the bizarrely misnamed liberal
democratic party
slyly suggested that other countries
should join in
the news agency reuters reported that
gironovsky sent letters to the
governments of poland hungary and
romania urging them to also annex parts
of ukraine that had once belonged to
their states gironovsky announced that
it is never too late to correct
historical errors
whether meant as a deliberate prank or
serious gironovsky's musings were
attuned to the precedence of many
partitions in the past of eastern europe
of course the most urgent question is
what precedents are being set now for
the future
as western leaders considered how to
react they repeatedly stated how
surprised they were and suggested that
putin must not know that we are after
all in the 21st century he was acting in
ways more fitting of past centuries
such repeated observations are troubling
because they suggest the comforting but
false notion that ages or centuries have
their own logic and spirit that must
move toward peace
on the contrary leaders and people set
the agenda for an age and there's no
automatic default mode of peace to rely
on in the absence of leadership no
natural law commands that the 21st
century should usher in harmony
the european union and the united states
condemn the putin regime's advances and
impose sanctions on trade with russia in
some cases quite reluctantly
in spite of ukrainian requests they did
not deliver arms to help in defense
nato was now on the front line of the
confrontation and poland in the baltic
states in particular urged vigilance and
action nato's concept of collective
security is written into article 5 of
its charter which states that an attack
on one member would be considered an
attack on all
in all of nato's life to date that
promise has been invoked only once after
the 9 11 attacks on the united states
would that promise hold in the future
how would so-called hybrid warfare that
is infiltrations and special operations
short of open invasion be met
what role would be played by other
potential flashpoints including the
isolated russian exclave of kaliningrad
a nuclear-armed island surrounded by
nato and eu members
while these remained open questions one
tragic reality was clear earlier
ukrainians and russians were bound by
many ties in history and proximate in
language and intermarriage as ukraine's
independent statehood began a majority
of ukrainians desired good relations
both with russia and the west
yet it is in the nature of war and
conflict that it forecloses many options
that peace might have offered
what the future offers the entire region
of eastern europe we shall explore in
our next and final lecture